I think the dynamic of the relationships
and marriages that I have seen work best
is where the wife is the husband's
number one fan and to the same degree I
think the guys should be the number one
fan of the wife if you think about like
what a fan is like a fan is somebody who
shows up first at all the concerts who's
the one who buys the T-shirt who's the
one who listens to their podcast who
even likes the stuff when they weren't
as good but then has the number one fan
feedback because they're rooting for
them in the long term that they want
them to get better but also to applaud
them for the short term success of doing
that they have if both people act like
they are each other's number one fan
they're going to be each other's number
one fan for life until somebody else is
the number one fan and then that person
gets replaced I think if you want to
make sure that you are always in that
person's life forever you just become
the number one fan and never let anyone
else be a bigger fan than you